no friends at the chess board have a
look this was pretty funny okay but when
you play a game of chess hun of course
when you're playing the opponent is you
and the opponent but you know in real
life you still like sometimes chest is
life that's that's what you don't
understand but the chess game is the is
the only thing that matters so but you
have some friends don't you Huns yes but
they're but I I take pleasure in their
pain what like when I see many many
people here when I see them lose I I but
this is this is not like a controversial
thing every one takes pleasure their
enemies losing this is not like people
just lie and say oh you know well I'm so
respectful oh I love oh we're just
everyone such no no no you and like I'm
sure this entire playing hole when I
lose they take Serious pleasure in them
okay I'm I'm just telling you I'm just
telling you but but you know we all uh
we all what about friendships H like
there's no friendships on the chess
board uh there's on the chess board but
what about outside of the CH chess is
life life is chess like the so you have
no friends the game of chess continues
on and off the board okay it is a
continuous In Perpetual game of chess
until
death a Perpetual gain of Chess until
death okay I mean there are no friends
on the chess board or the
philosopher chess is life like chess
exactly and we are out to kill one
another sort of sort of like what he's
saying obviously as a chess coach is
this how how you rally the troops and
say come on guys
everybody's different right everybody's
different everybody reacts differently
to a different steaming light uh so this
is exactly what's happening with Hans he
loves to be it seems like he's getting
some inspiration from being hated
supposedly at least in his mind he
thinks that he's being hated it's him
versus the world and uh you know when in
his mind it's him versus the world
that's his attitude I have no friends
over chessboard or outside the
chessboard chess is life and we're
playing until death so that's kind of
what he brings brings to the table I
love it I like it how about you guys I
like the line of Mogadishu he was saying
that uh you know I need more haters all
all the haters I have have become my
friends that's right I need more haters
that's right maybe not a bad thing I
thought it was a pretty funny line I
mean need more haters Kate jump in on
this I don't know like liking when your
friends lose I I don't agree with that
or your teammates or yeah like teammates
your schoolmates you know your no but he
doesn't have any friends that's the
thing he doesn't have any friends he
said I don't have any
friends that but you know that was
always very difficult for me like I I
had a lot of very close friends growing
up and we would go to these tournaments
all the time and we had what we call
Brotherhood pairings like we get paired
you know we go from Seattle to Portland
and then we get paired against one
another in the rounds and was like no I
could always play you in Seattle so I
had trouble playing against my friends
uh over the board because I didn't want
to lose I didn't want to beat them I you
know so this was always tough but h no
problem I'm curious how he would do at
like Olympic team event or world team
event because there he has to cheer for
his friends or enemies and Away you go
uh I dare not ask